so what I did will I turn around I
bought sir buying houses any worst city
I would buy a house for $40,000 and I'd
buy and I in the name of let's say Alan
Duncan or Brandon green so I buy it for
40,000 and that's somebody who created a
completely figuring this person so I
then turn around assistant they call him
now they call him since like back then I
just it was just a phantom borrower okay
but now they call him synthetic
identities okay so I turn around I would
go to public records I was dating a girl
at a title company and she explained to
me that if you paid the additional doc
stamps document stamps on a the sale
then the sale shows up higher so I
bought it for 40,000 but if I pay an
extra seven to nine hundred dollars
it'll show up for a hundred and sixty
you have to do the math but one hundred
and sixty thousand one hundred forty
thousand dollar sale so the house I just
bought for forty thousand now looks like
I bought it for 160 or 200 or 190
whatever I want I based it off square
footage I started saying okay you know
one hundred and ten hundred twenty
dollars a square foot in Ybor City yeah
so I'm buying houses that are 1,400
square feet they're appraised that I'm
recording the valley I'm buying 440
recording the value or the sale at 190
180 but I'm bald one in the name Brandon
green one in the name James red yeah so
I've got one here one here one here so I
started buying them all over what
happens is when you send out the
appraiser the appraiser goes in and says
man what a piece of garbage house this
is I cleaned it up a little bit alright
but he be like this is a rough area and
I said yeah you bought it for 190 yeah
yeah this whole area is going up yeah
they go well you know there's
comparables everywhere though you know
that house over there sold for 190 no
that one over there sold for 200 oh yeah
and you own them all the neighborhood's
going up right down the addresses for me
he's like yeah check that out comes back
because I can't believe it I got you an
appraisal for a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars that's crazy
thank you so much well then I take that
I send it into the lender the lender
says yeah well I mean there's documents
that have to support it of course so I
have supporting documents
of course I'm making those documents
yeah and if they would need it to be
verified well I'll come up with a cell
phone or I'll come up with a landline or
a website whatever I really need them up
with I'm gonna come up with I've degree
in fine arts I'm fairly creative yeah so
you know I'd come up with the documents
and they're the verifications and since
I've been in the mortgage industry I
knew what they were gonna ask for what
are they looking for
mm-hmm what's the tax ID number where
are they gonna look for it how can I
piggyback off of a real tax ID number on
a w-2 and they won't verify it or if
they do try and call it they'll call
they'll go online and they'll look it up
in the what used to be the business
white pages well you can go online and
put your business on it mm-hmm so now
they're calling a cell phone that's in
the name of a guy that doesn't exist to
verify it or there's something called HQ
have your heard HQ it's a they're these
offices that you can rent they're
they'll be on like the 30th floor don't
some building downtown offices well
there'll also for 40 or 50 bucks they'll
answer your phone they'll forward them
be able to collect your mail they're for
your mail so seems like you got a
real-deal business and yeah I got a real
business real in business card address
so these these loans start closing I buy
them for forty fixing them up for ten
borrowing a hundred and fifty walking
away with 90 with a hundred thousand
dollars in each guy I'm buying at least
five or six houses so you're getting
about two about a million dollars worth
of loans you're walking away with five
or six hundred thousand dollars Wow and
that worked like a charm for a long time
I want you to do it for about two years
about two years eleven point five
million is what they we borrowed in
about two years so and and every time
the loan would go through the first
payment would always default or no no I
oh of course I'm not an idiot
I mean I I would pay three or I pay
three four or five months okay sometimes
I rent them out sometimes I just if it
the place was trashed or I just make the
payments at least three or four months
keep in mind too I'd then turn around I
borrow personal loans I didn't get about
30 $40,000 worth of credit cards because
now this guy's got multiple mortgages
right credit so now I can borrow I can
get a bunch of credit cards I get a
bunch of credit cards those guys were
worth about five six hundred thousand so
I pull the money out
you know and we would do really just
stupid things you know I had like a
drawer filled up with socks that I'm
never gonna wear got 60 pairs of
underwear that you know it's just just
stupid you don't even know what did you
know I don't really know and I'm
thinking it's gonna last forever because
I'd figured out that when they would go
into foreclosure
they'd start going into foreclosure they
start sending letters and I get the
letters and I would I would take an
article so I'm like let's say the Tampa
Tribune of a five car pileup or a 20-car
pileup and I retype the entire article
and I put insert my guy's name James
read into the article and it's a James
read was life flighted to Tampa General
Hospital and so I would print out the
article on newsprint and make a copy of
that then I'd write a letter from James
Reds sister and saying listen my brother
was in an accident here's the article
highlighted the doctors say even if he
wakes up from the coma he'll never work
again you might as well go ahead and
foreclose on the house and so they just
stopped sending in the letters yeah they
just flows they just they make a few
phone calls but they get that letter
it's over they take the house back and
they never come looking so it worked
really well yeah sounds like it
so we got to make sure you cover all
your hands and stuff you know yeah I did
you know I I there were one or two times
when for instance there was a buddy of
mine he's in Tampa and still in real
estate so I won't mention his name he he
was in charge of making the payments on
this one guy he was like look I'm
juggling right you're I'm juggling your
hands full eight people yeah everybody's
sharing in the profit you got ten grand
from the last one you got 20 you got 15
you know I can't be expected to make all
of these payments yeah he's up with the
right so here here's red you're gonna
make the payments for it another memory
it was uh it was Alan Alan Duncan it was
Alan Duncan cuz it was one of my first
ones I done and he's about to foreclose
so I'm like here's Duncan you make the
payments on the house we just bought
which was like the last house we're
gonna make a few payments all of them
are going in foreclosure so he didn't
make the first payment
and I remember the mortgage broker she
comes to my house and she says oh my god
Oh Sal star Bank Sal star Bank I don't
know if they're still around but Sal
star bank just called they can't get
ahold of Alan Duncan they said they know
that the bank accounts are fake they
know like they just started no we know
this we know this we know this you've
got a problem so I find out I go to the
guy the guy said what that what happened
and he says oh my god I forgot to paint
make their first payment I didn't know
was due already so I get them on I get
Southstar on the phone I call up and I
say listen this is Alan Duncan I just
talked with you know this guy I forget
what his name was I say John Smith
Johnson and they go oh he's in a meeting
I said well this is Alan Duncan I assure
you he wants to talk to me immediately
please
interrupt the meeting it's extremely
important so the secretary interrupts
and boom they put me on the phone and
it's their head of fraud department some
lawyer and like a vice president of the
bank Wow and they're like okay mr.
Duncan and I'm like yes they're like
okay well we've been we've spent quite a
bit of time looking over your uh you
know your your file here yeah and I'm
like okay and they said we got $140,000
loan to a man that doesn't exist because
we know you don't exist and I'm like
okay well listen I'm not sure where this
is coming from I mean I I understand I I
missed a payment its I'm putting it in
the mail today we should have this all
day oh no it's too late for that this is
too late for that
and so I went okay well let me catch up
the payment and he's like no no he's
like look you know the works it we're
gonna submit this to the FBI we're gonna
do a full investigation you're gonna end
up I remember he kept saying like a it
was something like a 6 by 6 or an 8 by 8
concrete box I remember he kept saying
that yeah you're gonna end up in an
eight by eight concrete box and anyway I
said to him ah you know they were real
cocky about it mm-hmm and I'd been
caught before I got caught one time with
two million dollars but the loans had
already been part of the package ever
been sold the household bank and the
lender didn't he wasn't willing
push the issue because it was several
million dollars he was gonna be on the
hook for yeah so he just continued to
sell the paper right and so he let me
off and came back and told me to keep
sending loans this is when I own the
mortgage but these guys were cocky
mm-hmm and I remember thinking so as
we're talking I i I was like okay
they're not there they're really cocky
about this and so at one point I said
okay I don't understand I said aren't
you guys concerned about getting your
money back I mean well you know I'm
trying to give you your money back here
and they said Oh we'll get our money
back when we foreclose on property and I
went oh I said now I get it
you think that your hundred and forty
thousand dollar loan is attached to a
property worth 180 and it they're like
right I said no now now things I got
always like now things aren't gonna
shift like in my favor I can feel it so
I said okay let me explain what I do
what I did
do you have your um do you have the
appraisal in front of you yeah
so they I'd send them obviously our
appraisal they done what's called a
desktop review where they review it but
they don't actually go out to the
property they review it they have an
appraiser review it and I explained look
take a look at comp number one that's
owned by a guy named Lea black comp
number two you know James red comp
number three you know David silver and I
explained what I did I did this pay the
docs aunt boom boom boom I told him all
I have to at this point I got to try and
convince generally angle he's it right
I'm done anyway yeah so I said look
here's the deal and they so they're like
oh my god I said right so I said as you
can see you now you have a piece of
property that I bought for $40,000 I
paid an extra eleven hundred dollars to
get it to appraise at 180
you know the appraiser had blued
everybody involved the appraiser did
exactly what he's supposed to do he
didn't do anything wrong the mortgage
broker has never seen me she did
everything by the telephone she doesn't
have any clue what's going on every
single document was provided by me you
lent the money your underwriters lent
the money doing exactly what they do
everybody involved in the transaction
does what they do it on a daily basis
and I walked away with the money now if
you want to get your money back you'll
let me cut you a check and you'll agree
not to contact the FBI so we end up
working out an agreement where they let
me cut them a check
that's not the only time that happened
I've had it happen with Washington
Mutual caught we'd done like eight
owner-occupied properties one time you
understand occupy properties like your
house is an owner occupied property
right if you go by a rental property
it's a rental property right Lynch about
80% right maybe 70 well I had a realtor
that had bought eight duplexes all of
them we said were owner-occupied with
eight different lenders got caught that
time ended up that several of the those
duplexes were on Washington Mutual
credit lines with different lenders and
they all Washington Mutual ended up with
all of them and they figured out we've
got three not all eight but they had
like three so their lawyer contact just
said look this is what you did this is
illegal this is this this is that and of
course they don't even know that the
w-2s are fake they don't even know how
bad it is yeah so I convinced them to
take like thirty thousand dollars less
money to just let us refinance him and
the lawyer accepted that he was okay
with that
really it's insane
[Laughter]